we appreciate the support of our
sponsors to find out how you can be part
of the next what if discussed
contact sales at notorious.llc
energy drinks have a spectrum there's
the stereotypical energy drink
the one that people usually think of
which is high caffeine high sugar
and then there's the other end of the
spectrum which is green tea
b vitamins natural sweetener and that's
it
so it's very difficult to say all energy
drinks are healthy or unhealthy you have
to look at the specific ingredients
and the caffeine content
peter what my name is richard garner
and i am an energy drink aholic
i was you always start off the show very
dramatically with something like that i
wasn't sure
uh what was going to happen today but
apparently today we're in the middle of
an intervention is that
and i'm only half kidding like i mean
and i certainly don't want it to seem
like a making light of the 12-step
program or people
in uh real uh you know aaa meetings
whatever it because the truth of the
matter is by all definitions
i would be considered addicted to energy
drinks
my day starts like starts when you say
starts means like wake up
it's like i have literally crack a
a monster red bull whatever is really on
sale to be honest maybe like there's no
difference in taste
there is there is a different taste but
it tells you it's not about the taste at
the end it's about
it's about the getting jacked is that
what you say well it's about it's about
yes
but waking up i would say that is out of
the ordinary
and i from all i've heard about energy
drinks
is uh i've never had one myself did you
wow
you know they've been around for years
and years and years for cease to i've
never had a single one
you're waking wake and bake basically
that way could bake as a whole other
show by the way but i would say if i was
saying i i woke up and
had a coffee right away you wouldn't
think that's crazy i wouldn't and i know
where you're getting at because coffee
is
caffeine is a drug and that's obviously
uh you know
not necessarily good for you either but
it's just a widely accepted
coffee tea even beer and and spirits
it is and we live in a world where again
it's it's not always just because
it's legal that it's right or just
not a lot of people have studied this
but thankfully our guest today
has studied this because this is an area
that i think is just emerging
as something we need to understand more
about uh whether it's fatigue whether
it's how people
sort of manage stimulating themselves
whether they should be at all
but that is why we are welcoming today
danielle robertson wrath
caffeine scientist author speaker and
really
one of the only people i know that
studied this area as much
as pretty much anybody out there the
author of
are you a monster or a rock star
danielle robertson wrath
welcome to what if disgust thank you so
much for having me
so i mean i guess it's a it's a fair
question off the top because i think
most people like peter
they default to energy drinks are bad
yeah
and most of the studies or articles you
read
reflect that so they they but they
usually are sort of combined with
you know if you're having six or seven a
day or this so let's just get started on
that
um first question where
do you fall on whether they're sort of
healthy or not healthy energy drinks
well that is a very tricky question it's
tricky to say
energy drinks are healthy or they're
unhealthy for the same reason it's
tricky to say cereal is healthy or
unhealthy
on one side of the spectrum you have
lucky charms on the other side of the
spectrum you have
raisin bran and so energy drinks have
a similar spectrum there's the
stereotypical energy drink
the one that people usually think of
which is high caffeine high sugar
and then there's the other end of the
spectrum which is green tea
b vitamins natural sweetener and that's
it
so it's very difficult to say all energy
drinks
are healthy or unhealthy you have to
look at the specific ingredients and the
caffeine content
so as uh richard so helpfully pointed
out at the top caffeine
uh from coffee may be uh just as bad but
uh
you mentioned green tea as being a good
one that's full of caffeine as well
and coffee is the the drink of choice
for most people that i know at least on
this continent
um how do the two stack up energy drinks
and coffee
well there's a lot of differences which
we probably don't have time to get into
here but there's three key differences
between
coffee and energy drinks the first is
that the caffeine content
isn't what you'd expect people that love
their
coffee sometimes look down on or worry
about
people that have their energy drinks but
a
grande brew coffee from starbucks is
equal to three red bulls okay
so one grande coffee is the caffeine
content of
three red bulls i'll give you another
one one
grande pumpkin spice latte is about
one can of monster energy or one and a
half red bulls
so you really have to look at the
caffeine content and not be focused on
is it a coffee with its healthy halo or
an energy drink with its
negative stereotypes yeah that's the
first difference the caffeine content
the other thing
is that energy drinks are really good
about telling you how much caffeine
is in the container that's part of their
best practices it's
really hard to know how much caffeine
you're getting with coffee
because it's a natural product they
don't have to label the amount of
caffeine
so it's very difficult to know how much
caffeine you're getting
and then the third key difference
between coffee and energy drinks is
what other people are in that party it's
called the food matrix so with coffee
you're just getting
caffeine and water and antioxidants with
energy drinks
you might be getting taurine b vitamins
glucuronolactone other ingredients so
you have to look at
the whole picture you have to look at
the whole food matrix
and coffee because it's simpler is often
but not always healthier because there's
fewer things but if you're adding cream
and sugar
that might not be true you have to look
at every every piece of the puzzle
well like most things on the show are
otherwise
a little more complex than initially
thought
uh we're gonna continue with danielle
robertson wrath
uh after the break more on what if
discussed
what if discussed is brought to you
today by keeps you know as guys so much
of our identity is wrapped up in our
hair that's why as we get a little older
and start noticing the first signs of
hair loss it definitely feels like
panic time face that no guy is ever
ready to go bald so
thankfully there's now there's keeps the
simple and easy way to
keep your hair yeah the numbers are
actually a little more startling than we
might think
two out of three guys experience some
sort of male pattern baldness
by the time they're 35 feet so it's
something you have to get on while you
still have the hair
well you can get treated from home you
used to have to go to the doctor's
office for your hair loss prescription
but now thanks to keeps
you can visit a doctor online and get
hair loss medication
delivered right to your home they
deliver your medication every three
months so you can say goodbye to
pharmacy checkout lines and
awkward doctor visits and
it is a long process four to six months
before you really start seeing the
results but there's plenty of
testimonials of people that are super
happy with
that and are happy they did it but you
got to get started because the sooner
you start the more hair you
keep for lack of a better way to say it
no they'll love that if you're ready to
take action
and prevent hair loss go to keeps.com
what if to receive your first month of
treatment for free that's k
e e p s dot com slash what if
welcome back to what if discussed we are
with danielle robertson wrath
the author of are you a monster
or are you a rock star is that right is
that did i get the title right danielle
yes yes are you a monster or a rock star
a guide to energy drinks and
so it is a title by the way it is a
great title but it's also a helpful
book in in that this is an area that a
lot of people
uh don't really understand there is
information out there there's not tons
of studies
uh there's articles you you know you
talked off the top of most of them skew
towards they're not good
but not surprisingly most articles about
coffee
skew towards that's good and
we talked with danielle in the first
part of the show about well some of
that's also misleading yeah
more information on that um
in the end they're they're delivery
systems right i mean that's the one
thing we haven't really talked about
it's whether it's coffee whether it's
caffeine pills
uh whether it's energy drinks these are
systems that are
designed to sort of deliver caffeine um
does the science in the end support
long-term
moderated caffeine use as healthy
yes yes it does in fact there was
a giant giant research paper i mean
50 pages a systematic review published
in 2017
in the journal of food chemistry and
toxicology
and they looked at decades worth of
research on
caffeine from all different sources
coffee tea
energy drinks food with caffeine they
concluded
what papers before them have concluded
that if you stay
under 400 milligrams of caffeine per day
then there's no increased risk for
things like cardiovascular effects
behavioral effects reproductive effects
or developmental effects
so that 400 milligrams is like the uh
what do you call it the pivot point on a
seesaw if you stay below that
the benefits of caffeine outweigh the
side effects
if you go over 400 milligrams of
caffeine then you start having more side
effects than benefits
interesting now this is ultimately
probably more of a conversation about uh
energy or specifically stimulation is
we're all looking for stimulation
and you know this may come under the
category of that's a story for
another what if but give us a give us a
picture about
uh the epidemic of fatigue what's what
has your research told you about why
we're so tired all the time
well there's two major causes of this
increase in fatigue the first one is our
screens
we're looking at our screens all the
time so that is messing up
our circadian rhythm that's the biggest
the biggest reason but the second reason
is that as
more and more products come out in the
marketplace with caffeine
people aren't drinking or aren't
consuming caffeine
as strategically as they can for example
we've been drinking coffee
forever so the average person knows that
coffee is good
they know they drink it in the morning
it's fine but they might not be thinking
about how that cup of coffee is
sabotaging their sleep
and so they drink caffeine at 3 p.m they
don't sleep well they wake up tired
they need more caffeine and it's just
it's a vicious cycle
so i believe that that is what's
happening and in fact
in michael poland's book caffeine he
makes the same exact mistake that a
rookie might
make he goes from having no caffeine
whatsoever to having this very strong
coffee with
extra shots of espresso that's
equivalent to not working out
for three years and then signing up for
crossfit or for a marathon
like you need to be more strategic with
how much caffeine you have how quickly
you drink it
and what time of day you're drinking it
and i don't think enough people are
doing that which is
why i do what i do i enjoy a nice
espresso
after supper i know espresso's got a
little bit less caffeine in it but is
that
ill-advised like you're saying after 3
p.m i heard you say is that
is that sort of the cut-off time for
drinking caffeine
that's what i recommend assuming that
you have a normal
schedule you're not working night shift
or anything assuming that you go to bed
around
10 p.m or midnight you want to cut
yourself off from caffeine around
three because it takes three to six
hours for
half of that caffeine to leave your
system so you want to give that caffeine
enough time to be metabolized before you
try and go to sleep and 3 pm is a good
cut off point
for caffeine to leave your system well a
lot more to talk about a lot more to
dive into
pros and cons of energy drinks and
caffeine use
uh the management of it also i'd like to
get into a little more about the brands
themselves
you know which ones are quote unquote
better healthier if any of them are
um danielle can you stick around for a
little more
absolutely so we are going to continue
with danielle robertson wrath
talking caffeine talking energy drinks
um
but uh for the maybe we'll talk a little
bit about sugar too
and yeah that which is actually a big
you know sugar free or not sugar is also
a big part of this it's a good point
uh but for the youtube viewers uh where
can they go well if you're watching us
on youtube right now there's a link
right below
you can see yeah click on that and you
can get the extended audio podcast where
we'll have more with caffeine scientist
and author
danielle robertsonrath if you're
listening already on the podcast there's
nothing for you to do just stay tuned
and you'll hear the rest of us but if
you are leaving thanks for joining us
and we'll see you next week on what if
[Music]
discussed